Hey,
what's going on is Bill Byrd is time for
the Monday morning podcast from Monday.
Uh,
what is it?
September 24th,
2018 what's going on? How are
Ya? Just realize my flies down.
Am I at that age now?
50 years old and be that
guy walking around doesn't
even always flies down here.
Where are my glasses?
I still haven't fixed this.
All I do is just bitch about this wire
rather than going out and getting it
fixed. Why would you do that bill? All
right. I just flew back from Charleston,
South Carolina for that house in Richmond.
40,000. Not Norfolk, Norfolk, Virginia.
I was down in the fucking,
saf had a great time.
He had a god damn great time. I got
to tell you some Richmond, Virginia,
the Altria Theater, uh, top five,
top five theaters in America I've
ever played. That there was the,
I dunno, I dunno what it
was. The whole layout of it.
That dome above how great the sound was.
The crowd was amazing.
It was incredible. You know, I know what
she's all, what about us? And Norfolk.
I had great time there too.
Great crowds the whole fucking time.
Great people. They didn't lose their
houses because of the hurricane.
I haven't been to fucking
North Carolina yet. You know,
I was so relieved and when
I got to Charleston because
they said that thing was
going to hit him dead center,
you know,
and uh, I was like, want to,
so what am I going to show up?
Everybody lost their house. I'm going
to come down there being like, oh,
what's up with this fucking wire on
my party? Like a ditch and about that.
People just lost their house. I
didn't want that. I was so relieved,
so relieved that I didn't
have to go to design.
Don't ever send me to a disaster area.
I am much better hundreds,
if not thousands of miles away doing a
benefit where the money is then sent to
that area. You get me in the
area, my act, my act as not work.
Yeah.
When people are knee deep in water in
their living room, it just doesn't, okay.
I've tried. It doesn't work
and it's just, you know,
it's just not a good thing.
But you know, it's, you know,
there's other comics for that. It's
a great big, beautiful fucking world,
a comedy. Um, anyways,
I flew back today and, uh, guess who
was sitting next to me on the plane,
Frankie Valli. I couldn't
believe it. I was freaking out
sky and you know, I, I didn't bug him.
He was literally right next to me and
his whole vibe was he didn't want to be
bugged.
So I did not fucking,
I didn't say one fucking word
to him other than excuse me,
cause I had the window, you know, and uh,
the guys like 84 years old, you should
have seen him popping up out of his seat,
the end of the flight to grab his bag.
You know,
are we expecting someone
to bug him? And, uh,
incredible shape kept himself
in like I eat fucking ways.
The exact same you way back when
he was singing all those songs,
it's very inspiring.
MMM.
Actually when I looked him up,
one of the questions that
people ask what you know,
all like all the top questions.
One was how did Frankie Valli die?
You know, that's when you
know you crushed it in life.
Yeah.
You've been living so long. People just
assume that you're dead. I don't know.
I was pretty impressed by that. I hope I
live that long. When did bill burr die?
Uh,
he's still alive.
You can go see him down at the fucking
Hooky Lao and chickopee Massachusetts.
MMM.
All right. What's your favorite Frankie
Valli Song? What? Mine is mine. Is that,
remember that song? Yeah. Yeah.
Mazza Georgia.
Okay.
Though I never laid a hand on you.
My eyes door June like itself.
Then it Salvey good.
Z Iboga back door.
Joe.
So close. So close yet. So far.
Okay.
He sat next to me on the plane.
I didn't fucking say shit to him.
He just,
that you know,
eight I was enough. It was
enough. He was fucking automatic.
It's pseudo did you will
ignore a really big fan. Great.
Now we used to go wash his hand.
MMM.
So if you see him, you know, fucking
lean Multnomah Salem street. It was,
it was his mood.
Today I'm talking like I know the guy
I did set next sit next to him for like
fucking three hours
when we were done,
if I just started singing his
fucking stuff, I was, you know,
I just put on my fucking headphones.
They just started singing his shit
song. She Sung like 9 million fucking
times. Then he has to hear him.
Disgustingly attitude.
Okay.
Probably would elbowed me. Hey Kid, shut
up. I did it better. Something, you know,
some cool something that are
called gay would say, man,
I hope I'm in the shape.
He's,
I hope I live that long and I
hope I'm in the shape he's in.
He looks fucking great and uh,
okay
for gay. He still sings his ass off.
So that was pretty cool. I'll tell you,
what was it called?
I'll tell you what I did enjoy.
Yeah.
Was how the New England
patriots got their asses.
Why Bunch of Goddamn nerds,
oh,
this happens every September.
Every September we start off slow and
then everybody has this dead and buried.
It's fucking over every setting. The new
tradition in the AFC is in September,
the Patriots are done and Kansas
City's going to the super bowl.
How many times have we seen it? Well,
it's only the second year in a row. Well,
it feels like five.
Okay.
Kansas City, it's over. It's a gift.
Wrap it up in a fucking bow. Right?
Fucking unbelievable fucking Versie man.
For as he jinxed me,
he fucking tease the Patriots.
I didn't even give him shit.
That's the second week in a row that
he's lost on the lions as he calls him.
The hapless lions.
Fucking unbelievable.
Not as unbelievable as this God damn
fucking wire. Oh, did I move my head? Oh,
is this a comfortable position?
And now go fuck yourself. Um,
okay.
I was actually doing,
I did two shows last night.
My wife taped the game so
I haven't even seen it,
but I was watching the ticker on my
phone cause I don't know how you guys,
you fucking download the app and
then you gotta have your pen.
How do you keep all your
passwords? Well, how do you keep,
how do you keep track of them?
You know,
unless you just don't give a fuck and
you just use the same one every God damn
time.
Okay.
I'm a, I'm not even good at
coming up with passwords.
Like when I go to type it in that
the computer's like week, Eh,
that's getting better.
And I'm like,
I'm like fucking Zebra
[inaudible] 98 they're like fair.
It's like how the fuck is,
somebody's going to figure that out.
Okay.
Anyways.
Um,
okay.
Balloon Herbie 49 week like this
to somebody already have that.
I have no idea.
But let me ask you this.
When was the last fucking time he is
a God damn stats, Foy stats or stat?
He's a fucking stat for you. When was the
question? I have, when was the last time?
The browns,
the lions and the buffalo bills.
All one in the same week.
Jesus Christ.
I mean, you're talking the browns
in the lions have both gone. Oh,
and 16 in this decade,
right?
Was it this decade under the years
of flying by 32 fucking losses.
You know,
they always do that when they talk about
the national debt and they tried to put
it in terms that you can understand.
I'm going to put 32 losses in terms
that you can understand. Lost, lost,
lost, lost, lost, lost,
lost, lost, lost, lost.
I'm going to fucking do times three plus
two. Lost, lost a lot of fucking losses.
Um, somebody's going to use that as a
rink. Film loss loft. Sorry. Anyways,
um, it's weird. My team is one and two.
We actually have a worse record
right now than the Cleveland browns.
Having said that,
it's kind of fucking fun seeing these
teams that have sucked so long be good.
I want, does anybody out there
call a buffalo bills? This
maybe a bad on it, but who
the fuck? Who the fuck saw
27?
Nothing.
Okay.
Whatever the fuck they were up by 17.
Nothing
against the fucking bite.
What a viking stove.
The vikings putting their fans out of,
out of their misery early this year.
They usually wait till the playoffs.
Playoffs.
Okay.
Um, I watched a bunch of
football this weekend. I watched,
I watched Alabama roll tat.
I watched them against the Aggies.
Love the Aggies quarterback.
Man, that guy's a fucking game.
He kept a minute for like a hat almost
to the half, but uh, I swear to God,
watching, watching the,
uh, Alabama crimson tide,
it's like watching the patriots where
the players are so well coached.
Like the way they turned it on at
the end of the first half to be like,
hey,
let's get another touchdown here and
let's buy whatever the hell they were by.
Like I think, I can't
remember, maybe seven.
Let's go in the locker room up by four.
They put the foot on the gas and then
went right down the fucking field and they
scored. Aggies come out,
they shut them down again.
They got the ball back and
then they kicked a field goal.
They tacked on an extra fucking 10 points
and it was like, wait a minute, wait, we,
we were down by one score. We've done
by a touchdown like three minutes ago.
We're ready to jargon, you know,
feeling good about ourselves.
And all of a sudden they give him the
whole fucking right there, Fred twice.
And then the,
uh,
Alabama was getting the ball coming
out of halftime and you liked it.
They're going to go down,
they're going to score another touchdown.
It's fucking game is over.
That's essentially what they did.
And the fact that, uh, Nick Saban,
I always go to forget his name and I just
remember that chant when I went to the
Lsu game and the whole student
section was going, fuck you save.
So I always have to say
that once in my head,
I have to picture of that memory and
then the audio plays. Fuck you save.
And I called Nick, Nick Saban, Nick Saban.
MMM.
The job that that guys doing down
there, considering, you know,
all the players that you lose every year,
everybody thinks they're a pro or they're
just a senior and they can't play any
more and you're just constantly
rebuilding the fact that they,
that whatever the hell he instills
in them, they get it immediately.
Um, you know, it was pretty
impressive. I miss the Lsu game.
Fucking college football is
like the Games don't like on,
they'd like random games on like
Tuesdays now it seems so on Friday.
I think I missed that. But they're three.
No, I think we got Florida next week.
I did say we, I'm in, I'm in
with fucking Lsu. I, I, you know,
can't, can't root for Alabama. They
just took God damn good. Right.
I'm not looking forward to that
Alabama game. That's going to be rough.
But who knows?
Maybe dead fucking Cajun Hulk
Hogan can talk them into s I dunno.
I Dunno. You know what? That'd be fun.
I got to watch Alabama every week
cause I never watched when they lose.
How angry does nick say?
I actually worry for his loved
ones when that guy's taking a loss.
Okay.
Like that poor Alabama kicker.
We fucking Shank two punts.
The fucking look on Nick Saban's face.
Oh my God. It was like he wanted to
rip the kids fucking foot off. Um,
anyways, I hate fucking podcasting
when I flew across the country fly.
I don't know what it is.
All my funny just goes out the window,
but brain isn't working
fucking sitting here.
Jesus Christ. Um, so how was
I going to talk about, I,
I absolutely nothing to fucking
talk about. How many minutes of,
I'm 12 minutes in 12 fucking
minutes and I got one for you.
You know somebody come home,
right?
All I want to do is jump in the shower
and just wash the fucking airport off of
me. All right? Can't do it.
Cause I own an old house and we got a
plumber in here for the 9 million time
trying to fix whatever the fuck is
wrong with the, the toilet this time.
Can't do it. I swear to God, give you
guys some advice. If you ever fucking,
somebody ever describes a house has
having character, I'm telling you,
just head for the hills. All right?
If you meet a woman and she says,
guys find me intimidating. Just
run for the hills. Does it?
There's a couple of fucking
red flags out there. Um,
ladies, what are we? And tell me what,
what is it so I can help out women here?
What, what's the, uh,
what's the red flag with a guy
you don't know him and he says drink lists
something creepy. I
don't fucking know. Um,
anyways,
the red sox clinched that was all exciting
until the Yankees clinched and it's
just like, oh, so are both zero and zero.
Like what am I getting excited about?
Why is everybody popping
fucking champagne and all that?
The Indians won the series. I think
they took two out of three from us.
I'm telling you,
Terry Francona is laying in the
weeds and nobody sees this guy.
Okay.
People, how many times do I
have to be right? I, I'm, I'm,
I'm going to pat myself on the back
right now. I had been killing it lately.
I said it wasn't fucking open when we
swept the Yankees. I was right. I said,
you can't base the lines first fucking
week or what they're gonna do or anybody.
I was right about that.
All right.
I was worried about two things,
but that feels great to me.
Felt like I've been right
about a lot of shit. You know,
this is what happens when you get married.
You know what I mean?
When you actually write about something,
you just, you want to tell people.
So there's maybe somebody will give
you a fucking had a boy every once in a
while. Um, anyways, I, uh,
what else? What I want to fucking
absolutely. Literally nothing.
Charleston football. Oh yeah, yeah.
There's another isn't a
fucking sign of global warming.
Isn't it amazing how like sports,
like they, they don't give a fuck.
They'll talk about war,
they'll promote a war and all that shit.
But for some reason, global warming
or climate change, whatever that is,
just completely off limits.
I have never seen,
I never saw a football game called
or delayed because of weather.
The first, like, I dunno, 45 years
of my life, 40 years of my life,
and now it's like every
other fucking week.
Like the weather is too
bad to play football,
which you play no matter
what the weather is.
So either somebody sued the shit out of
a stadium because they just got a perm
and it started to rain and a football
game or we're just getting crazier and
crazier whether
you know it's gonna happen eventually,
you know, because we keep
saving all of these people.
When Mother Nature tries
to wipe him off the planet,
we fucking let everybody know
something is going to happen.
Get out of the fucking way.
So she's just going to have to start
swinging harder and harder and harder.
And it's going to be one
of these fucking times.
There's going to be a tornado that
sets down like write in a stadium and
everybody's just going to go flying
like they went through like a, like a,
a wood chipper.
Um,
you know something. If that fucking
guy, what the hell's his name there?
I always forget his name.
That guy, the guy he had als.
He was really smart and he was
always predicted negative shit.
I wish he was alive so I can ask him that.
Is it Steve or something like that?
Mike and one have regular names.
Hey Tim.
Billy.
Okay,
Kevin. Kevin's a little, it's
a little bad for white people.
That's a little flavor in your
name back in the day anyways. Um,
I would ask them to, hey dude, you know,
not for nothing. What, when, what year?
Yeah.
He was like,
he was like one of those fucking,
you know when you go to like Coney
island or something and you get like the
bearded lady and then there's
a guy guessing your weight.
He was like the guy that guests you
wait before, like super smart people.
He was always saying all that crazy shit,
you know?
Okay.
And 20, 38 there's gonna be no
more apples. You know, he just,
he added down the polar ice caps
are going to fucking, you know,
just fucking gloom and doom that guy had,
you know,
you guys think I'm bad. That
fucking guy, Jesus Christ.
I would have loved to ask
them and been like, hey Ricky,
when is a tornado going
to fucking set down?
Yeah.
In a fucking football stadium
that we don't even see coming.
He could actually probably
within the fucking week.
Well, actually, wait a minute.
What did that guy ever predicted came
true and I gotta be honest with a lot of
his predictions, they were pretty fucking
obvious. It's kind of was saying, yeah,
we're going to fuck this whole thing up,
which is kind of the direction we're going
in. But you know what your day to day
you gotta take like little,
like happy things that happen.
Like seeing the lions,
the bills and the browns all win.
You know, bills, fans a conch.
I've been to two games out there.
They're fucking grumpy cunt.
You know what I mean?
They'll like the south. They
never got over the loss, you know,
I'm fucking with you. Um, they never
got over those Superbowl losses.
They're just like, it's,
it's fucking with them.
It hangs over that city.
It's a great city.
They're great people. But I'm telling
you, do they put on a bill shirt?
I know the feeling, believe it or
not, back in the day I see it too.
Like whenever the red sox were that
the throwbacks with the pad patriot,
I get up my, me and my older
brother, we get sick to our stomach.
Okay.
When you look at it, he's like, oh
my God, I don't mind if they ever,
what they wearing with the black cleats
then it kind of looks like the original
days of the AFL.
I don't mind that.
But if they go out there with white
fucking cleats and they wear that fucking
Pat Patriot thing,
that's all I think about.
All I think about roughing the passer
fucking the 46 defense.
Dan Marino,
lightness up the buffalo bills where they
had Jim Kelly kicking the shit out of
us. Uh, there was a minute
there with the jets were good.
Okay.
When they had the New York sack exchange,
this can't all be football every week I
get people around the world listening to
this shit and they just don't give a fuck.
So I got up at some point,
switch off to something that's
going to be a little bit,
a little more mainstream.
Okay.
You know, I, oh, I also watched the,
sorry, I'll look there was watch football.
I watch the fucking Falcon Saints.
Um,
I dunno what the fuck is going on in
the NFC south, but that take the over.
None of those teams are going to win.
Shit.
Did you see those two fucking guys and
like their twenties couldn't track,
couldn't tackle 39 year old drew Brees.
Okay.
I was,
that was fucking ridiculous that if that
was a boxing match you'd say was fixed.
Um, but today, right now I don't
know what Matt Ryan's Diet is,
but I want to be on it.
Okay.
That guy,
he's gotta be like in his thirties now.
He doesn't get his fucking face is
all taking it looks like an astronaut.
Yeah,
those guys always have nice faces cause
they spent so many years out there in
the fucking space and is like no gravity.
Okay.
That's going to be like the next thing
that rich people do is everybody else
gets poor. They're gonna, they're
gonna just orbit the earth.
It's really good for your face.
It is going to be up there just
flying around. We're like no gravity.
You know,
if you're rich you get botox.
But if you're super rich,
you orbit the planet and you very
young, you know, want wanted to do that.
Wanted to go to like Mars or something.
Didn't lance bass want to do that shit?
The fucking people out of their mind.
Don't you know?
You don't remember when
that teacher went up.
Okay.
Then you remember like how much balls
it takes to be a fucking astronaut.
You getting on top of a stick of
dynamite, Yadda. Your fucking mind.
Yeah.
That's like chuck Yeager.
Shit.
Some fucking guy in a toll booth
yell get in that thing. Oh will you?
I think it's almost like,
yeah,
it's like it's disrespectful to the
other fucking people you know. Did they,
did they put you in that centrifuge and
shit before you go on there to make sure
you're not going to be yacking
all the way to the fucking moon?
Could you imagine that? The first,
you know the first one? The first one,
okay.
Okay. That they send up there with a
bunch of civilians. There is going to be,
somebody is going to freak the fuck out
and I guarantee you they are going to,
they're going to, they're going
to have something, some soda,
some guy just runs down the island
and just like puts a syringe. Right.
Do Your fucking neck so you don't freak
everybody else out when it finally hits
you that you're leaving the planet.
Like God,
there is so many things that
scares the shit out of me.
Yeah.
But I got to admit when George Clooney
just spun off into space and that fucking
movie, whatever the hell it was,
but he was so nonchalant about it,
like I didn't care about his character
and he's just like, Oh yeah, look at that.
There's a Serengeti. Oh he's like at this
time of year and he just floated off.
They made them to heroic. All
right. Cause I don't give a fuck.
You know how much balls you have as an
astronaut and you do you have balls the
size of my fucking head, which is
huge. If you don't know who I am. Um,
did you never taking a gander at it?
Um, I don't give a fuck who you are.
You start slipping off into fucking space.
I don't care how fucking bad ass you are.
It is the second you lose your grip on
the space station and you start floating
off and the other people in there asleep
or some shit and you're just, that's it.
You're done.
Okay.
There's no way you just go like,
well you know I had a nice run.
I guess I'm going to set
the record rebated space.
You know you're not going to say that
it is going to be at the line.
It
just fucking gone.
That is a fucking lonely
ass God damn death.
Could I be saying more obvious shit?
Oh is it bill to slip off into
the fucking space by yourself?
Now what happens
when you're up there?
Cause I know like some
fucking egg head figured out.
Okay,
why can I compliment them?
You know some guy who's way smarter than
I am somehow figured out that when you
went to space,
yeah,
because you are outside of the atmosphere.
The Sun's rays would be so god damn hot.
Yeah.
Your saliva would reach the boiling
point in your fucking mouth.
I remember that red bull guy when
he jumped, that was a problem,
like of his mass came off within, I don't
know how many seconds, like his, his,
he would lend,
it would go from like,
okay.
Hurdling through the atmosphere
with boiling water in your mouth.
Okay.
I mean,
you might as well get shot right directly
up your asshole with lightening at
that point that they just
make the Trifecta of horror.
MMM.
Hey,
remember the hole in the ozone layer?
How come they never fucking
talk about that anymore?
Is that thing going?
Do they fix it?
Oh my God.
I actually came up with an idea for a
fucking movie that I think you could make
a trilogy out of.
Okay.
And it's so ridiculous.
I'm actually,
rather than just saying it or
doing a fucking bit about it,
I actually just registered it,
registered it at the fucking writers'
guild on the way from the airport.
Okay.
Popped in there really quick.
It just fucking knocked it out.
MMM.
It's so like coming up with
this Scifi movie right now.
For some reason it's just really easy
because I feel like we're, we're,
we're there,
you know,
just all the shit that's fucking coming
out. All this shit that we're fucking up.
Nope.
60 years ago you had to
use your imagination,
you know ray guns and fucking pocket
doors that opened up what the Hedy,
your fucking body, whatever
happened on Star Trek, right.
MMM.
Teleporting and all of that shit you had
to like use your fucking imagination.
Now it's just like,
you know,
which skyping with each other.
Men Say Shit they did on Star Trek.
So I don't think it's that hard now to,
well actually you gotta be
ahead of the game. Right.
You know,
I haven't got an unlimited
would say this script is going to suck.
I'm probably going to
need some help with it.
Okay.
Yeah.
How funny it would be if I actually made
like a killer fucking trilogy of Phi
fucking movies and then every
other year when the movie came out,
I'd have to go to like fucking comic con.
That thing that I'd made fun
of so many fucking times.
I will actually went to it this year.
I had a great time.
People were actually cool. You know,
it's just fun to, I dunno what it is.
Isn't it fun to just make fun
of Shit that everybody likes?
Everybody gets all excited about something
and you just get to be a cunt. Um,
tickets are on sale for a, the all
things comedy festival. By the way.
We were trending today in all the,
uh,
the Hollywood reporter or variety
and all that, uh, this company,
all things comedy than
I am a small part of a,
we signed a deal with comedy central
to do four one hour specials,
the first one being Mr. Paul Versey.
Then we're going to do three other
killer ones for them next year.
We got some stuff in the works.
We're slowly becoming a little
fucking entity here, you know?
Oh freckles. He's built in
his own little kiosk out here.
That's how I view this business.
I view it like a giant fucking mall and
I got this little store right in the
middle. He knows once you walk by
and the guy is a little helicopter,
things that fly, you know which
cells key change. That's me.
I ain't fucking with Lord
and Taylor. Um, anyways,
plowing ahead and let me, let me
read, uh, uh, some of the, uh,
the advert or smudge the adverts.
It was something I wanted to go off on,
but I'm not going to fucking,
I'm not gonna fucking throw him.
I would just say this, you
know, uh, I can't fucking say.
You can't fucking say anything anymore.
He just, he gets fucking get in trouble.
You know,
there was a certain somebody on a certain,
something that was telling
people what they should have,
shouldn't be fucking saying in the same
business that this person was in and was
just like, wait, you know,
are you advocating censorship?
This is such a weird fucking,
these are lefties, lefties.
Um,
anyways,
is there anything worse than k?
When somebody does that?
There should be an APP.
You know
that if you ever Satan k like,
like so out of nowhere,
it just a giant like one of those
hall cans, but it's like padded,
just fucking punches.
You're right in the face.
You should never say that to
another human being. Mm. Kay.
Um, bookie, my, unless you're a
doing the voice on South Park,
uh, my bookie, everybody, you know,
ever since I started this podcast,
people had been asking me for advice.
Ask me what team to bet on. The truth
is, I don't know who's going to win.
Certainly not this fucking year.
Uh, but if you think, you know,
you got to check out my bookie,
remember who you're betting on is just
as important as who you bet and with,
it's a little brain teaser there.
That's why I'm telling
you to bet with my bookie.
Okay?
Yes. Not why it's cause it pay me
to tell you that. Trust me guys,
they're paying me. They are
the, your best bet this season.
They've been in business for years.
They have great reviews online.
That's a biggie.
Okay.
Degenerate gamblers usually
don't give good reviews.
They got good reviews
online. Great reviews, sorry.
And their mobile site is easy to use.
My bookie you,
when they pay you lose,
you know that you pay.
Yeah.
Depending how far you take it,
you might have to engage in a sexual
act that you never thought you'd dope.
They have in game live betting the most
rewarding player perks in the business.
And for Yo fantasy fantasy guys out there,
you can even bet on the over under
on how many third is the points.
A player will score each game.
My bookie is slammed with new betters
and wants to give everyone the best
service possible.
If you are willing to deposit after
7:00 PM eastern standard time,
they will give you an additional $25
free free to play on deposits over a
hundred bucks. That's pretty
cool, Huh? Join now and my book,
you will match your deposit dollar for
dollar use Promo Code [inaudible] to
activate the offer. Visit my
bookie online today. That's m Y,
B o, k, I. E.
And don't forget to use promo code bur
bur when creating your account to claim
up to $1,000 in free play.
And now if you're willing to hold out
until 7:00 PM like I just said to fucking
sentences ago,
you could get an extra $25 free play
by using pro Promo Code Bird 25 well,
you just said,
yeah.
Uh, when you claim when your account to
claim up to a thousand oh no, no, no.
There's some about a hundred
bucks on deposits over a
hundred dollars. All right?
You got to deposit 100 bucks to get the
25 and do it after 7:00 PM it's up to
you guys.
It's up to you.
But I would wait until after dinner and
take the extra money you play. You win,
you get paid. All right?
Simply say for everybody,
simply safe home security is home
security that finally gets it right.
What are the other ones do want to
take it out? The homeowner simply save.
Started 10 years ago with the
mission to fix the industry.
They cut out contracts,
middleman and pushy sales guys.
They made it easy to set up your system
with no hard wiring or tools with simply
safe.
You get professionally monitored,
24 seven protection for just $15 a month.
That's your home protected by police,
dispatch and fire dispatch.
Also known as first responders.
Everyone loves this system.
They love how it works and
how easy it is to use today.
Simply Save protects
over 2 million people.
They've one editor choice awards from
n e t PC magazine and wire cutter.
Those are got to be three the nerdiest
fucking magazines I've ever heard.
So you know,
they could go to simply safe bird.com
today to order your simply safe system you
get as 60 day risk free trial.
That's simply safe.
S I m P L I s a f e bird com.
Simply Safe bird.com
oh
look who's back. Everybody. But
who don't do me on Andy's undies.
The hurricane hit North Carolina
Doodoodoo to Mandy's Biondi.
He's hit him in the fucking vagina.
Okay,
now they're up to their
knees and tobacco and water.
Okay.
If your underwear's word, then you oughta
get, sorry, get some fucking me undies.
But Abbott Ebu, um, me,
Andy's the only people I trust
is the fucking Red Cross.
Whenever I donate after those fucking
things. You give it to the Red Cross,
you know,
Bu, Bu, Bu, Bu, Bu, Bu,
Bu, Bu, Bu, Bu, Bu, Bu why was that
the Red Cross? Um, no, that was, um, Mash.
Biondi is everybody you've heard me
obsessed over my me undies. Evidently.
You heard me talk about how they
are three times softer than cotton.
I never said that and come with fun
with new prints each month. Oh yeah,
I've definitely talked about that.
They do have fun new prints every month.
Three times softer than cotton. I Dunno.
I have no idea. I just know my junk happy.
Okay. Well my junks happy. I get
a little spring in my step kids,
my wife on the cheek. It puts
everybody in a good mood. You know,
if I wear regular underwear and exceed,
I'm slapping the parakeet.
Everything's fucking,
it's just off in the house.
Yeah.
I fucking hate people that own birds.
You know what I mean?
It's not bad to own a dog.
Thinks fucking stupid.
Was he go out there in the world? You
know, you can't let the fucking thing out.
It's too dumb.
You took all the wolf out of it,
right?
Yeah. The cat cats fucking
annoying. You know what I mean?
It comes and goes like a hookah.
Um,
Shit's all over the house and I
understand keeping that thing,
but a fucking bird man. It's supposed
to be out there flying around.
Okay.
You got the thing sitting in a god.
It is something about a bird in a
fucking cage. It makes me just wait.
I gotta finish this copy here.
It's, it really bothers me. Um,
and I would never slap a parakeet.
All right.
I'd flick it right and it's fucking beak.
Uh,
but I've got a big scoop that
I'm so excited to share with you.
Evidently me undies just gave
their membership a massive upgrade.
Members will also pay less
for everything on the me.
Andy's website was special member pricing.
That means if you want a
second pair of me undies,
a bralette or lounge pants,
hey ladies, you doing,
you'll pay less than anyone else. The
membership comes with no strings attached.
You can switch styles,
skip the month or cancel at anytime.
They come with a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee.
If you don't love them,
just them them back for
a full refund. Me, Ds me.
Andy's has a great offer for my listeners.
For any first time purchasers,
when you purchase any me ids,
you can get 50% off and free shipping.
Okay?
That's a no brainer.
Get 50% off a pair of the most comfortable
on these you will ever put on to a to
get your 15% off your first pair of
free shipping and 100% satisfaction
guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com
slash [inaudible] that's
[inaudible] dot com slash
burr you don't fucking commercials.
I hate whatever that cheap ass
underwear is that they show on TV.
Would that fat construction worker,
you know what I mean?
They're always like, no, no
sweat. No. It's like tow cheese.
It's the most disgusting
description ever. It's like, dude,
you're problem is not your underwear.
Your problem is you're a fat fuck.
That's what the problem is and there's
no one to wear out there that's going to
solve that. All right.
Eat a fucking salad.
Sorry.
But you know,
bless that company. They
saw a need. They like,
you know there's a lot of fat
people up there. They got, they got,
they got underwear riding up
their ass as well. They're,
they're driving their rigs.
I'm going to make underwear for them.
[inaudible]
anyways, stamps.com the US Postal Service
is an important tool for any business.
stamps.com is the easiest way to access
all the amazing services of the post
office. stamps.com never closes
like that. Easy checkup the street,
her fucking legs. Print
postage for letters or packages
at your convenience. 24,
seven print postage for any men. Uh,
male class, right from your own computer.
Buy and print official US postage
for any letter, any package,
any class of mail using your
own computer and printer,
they'll send you a digital scale that
automatically calculates exact postage.
This is my professional voice.
stamps.com we'll even help you decide the
best class of mail based on your needs.
No need to lease an expensive postage
meter and there are no long term
commitments. I use stamps.com whenever
I'm sending out my fucking posters.
I'm a moron if I could figure it out.
So can you,
and right now you can enjoy stamps.com
service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale.
Go To sans.com click on the microphone
and stop the homepage and type in Berber.
You are our that stamps.com enter burr.
Bam.
Okay.
All right.
That's it for fucking that.
Now evidently we go into the, uh, we go
into the questions here for the week,
for the week. Moto GP. Hey Bill,
I haven't heard you talk about
the guy in the moto g a moto race.
Who gripped the other guy?
Other racers breaks in
the middle of the race.
How the fuck did he do that?
Maybe I had my headphones out while some
shit head I work with felt it necessary
to tell me about his weekend.
I don't give a shit about,
but would love to hear your
thoughts on the incident.
I gotta I gotta check this out.
Here we go. Let's search here.
Modot modot modot fucking
GP Moto GP breaks.
Oh, break grab. There it
is. Let's see what we got.
You know what I was just sitting there.
Do you remember Super Fuzz, that movie?
And then they were in the transition
between one seat to another. They had the,
the background singers. They
go super, super, super, super,
super. Um, all right. Yeah.
Did this guy get banned for life? You
could fucking kill somebody doing that.
The caption literally says,
the guy's going like, he
wanted to kill me. All right.
I have to sit through a fucking
ad. Oh, and of course here we go.
Your ad will play.
Your video will play after this ad.
Remember the Internet when it didn't
have a bunch of ads, you know,
that was a great fucking time. Now they
just, they just punish you. I mean,
it's not as bad as listening to me read
ads and you always have the option of
fast 40 through mine. He's fucking
assholes. While let me do it. Come on.
I want to see it.
I want to see it. All right. This is
gonna take too long, unfortunately.
But this fucking guy grabbed onto was,
I don't want your fucking channels.
Fuck we meet alone.
You don't know he's a fuck. I mean,
when you're on the plane and the,
and the and the, they shut off your
movie to do a God damn commercial,
but some who the fuck is going
to sign up for a credit card?
60,000 free air miles.
That's enough to get you from here to
Chile and Bagley. Say all this dumb shit.
It's like, yeah, but you're not going to
let me do it. So what's the difference?
Right? I'll only be able to use
these during like the winter months.
You'll let me fly to fucking Alaska.
What is pitch black out? All right.
Evidently there's can't grab this
guy's fucking breaks. What happened?
I don't want to blame the victim,
but what in God's name did this guy do?
Moto GP. Grape break grab. I just have to,
let me just read about it here.
Okay.
Moto GP rider grabs competitors
break at 140 miles an hour.
This guy should be arrested.
How the fuck did he think that
no one was going to see this?
Does he realize it's televised?
Oh my God.
What a fucking asshole.
That's like right out of Wrestlemania
and the ref didn't see it.
Holy Shit. That guy's an amazing
writer. W that was his front brake to,
well I guess they always use the front
brake. It's a back. You don't want to use,
I don't know shit about motorcycles.
All right.
This grace mode to rider
Romano for naughty,
all the Italian. Ah, Jesus.
Then you know, at this finally,
no mob shows on TV.
They would turn in their fucking
reputation around and this guy's,
he's got to go full soprano on him.
The guy deservedly lost his spot
on the Marinelli snipers team.
All they kicked him off the team after
he attempt to one of the more dangerous
stunts we'll see in
competitive racing. Ah, man,
he's 22 years old. He's a fucking
hothead. He just ruined his career. Uh,
boy has fun.
Any road beside competitors
to Farnum Monsey.
I wonder if there's any history between
these two families. You never, no kidding.
At the San Marino GP.
The 22 year old reached out and grab
man sees break at 140 miles an hour.
Luckily man's,
he didn't fall off his bike and
Finetti's is it fanatics antiques were
completely called for.
That's one of the worst sentences.
Luckily Mansi didn't fall off his bike.
Oh,
as for Nannies,
antiques were completely uncalled for.
Phonetic was shown the black flag and
disqualified from the race for attempting
to harm an opponent.
While he was banned for two races
and fired from his team fanatic,
he thought the penalty was unfair.
Still,
he added that he had no
plans to race again. What
wow,
the world is. That world is close
to me. I'll not race any more.
He said an interview he
granted to the Lara Publica.
It isn't my world. There is. There's too
much injustice. I was wrong. That is true,
but nobody cares about my pain.
I was in a real man.
I was unable to control my anger, but
Mansi could have killed me too. Well,
what happened before that?
Dude, I'm telling you,
this is why you have to get into racing.
I, it's like the real housewives for men.
These fucking guys like how
mad they fucking get at each
other in the petty shit.
That's not really petty. But like
days of thunder, all of that,
you watch that movie, you like
Alice again, this is fucking silly.
Like that shit really goes down.
Okay.
I guess it's better than a car cause she
could fucking slam into people. It's,
you know, for some reason that's
not considered attempted murder.
MMM.
Wow.
I guess maybe because I have a temper,
I feel bad for that guy or also maybe
because I went after a dream and made it
come true and that kid did too,
and he just fucked up his dream.
I actually on some level feel bad for him,
uh,
that he's, maybe he was just emotional
after the fucking race and just said,
I'm done.
You know?
Uh,
I hope it just wasn't cause
he just couldn't beat the guy.
The guy was always getting
the best of them. You know,
many, we pulled like a bill.
Laimbeer you're like those players
whatsoever while you're better than me,
so I'm just going to wait till you leave
your feet and I'm just gonna take your
fucking legs out. That's still on
my favorite things of all time,
Bill and beer saying we tried to play
a mind game. It's like, you know, like,
like there was a lot of
layers to that. It's like, no,
you're just out there hurting
people. Um, all right.
Football and pizza. Oh
my God. Oh Jesus Christ.
This is one of the best ones ever.
Hey Yo, Billy colorless calves.
There's never been a truer statement.
My legs, I swear to you, they, they,
they are the color of milk.
Um,
I'm happy you're enjoying
getting in shape.
Most people don't get past
the first week of eating, uh,
eating well and a,
and it's a shame because it,
all it takes is one good week of
clean food and breaking a sweat. Well,
not if you like a hundred
pounds overweight, but I
know what you mean. He said,
I started doing long distance biking in
my twenties. You know what's hilarious?
I just had my bike fixed up.
I bought a bike in 1983 that I still have,
I bought a 12 speed with
my paper route money. Um,
okay.
I was 15 years old.
Yeah,
and I, I quit the my paper route the
year before, I think. I don't think, no,
I don't think I did.
I went from having a paper
route to have a part time job.
I do remember that I had a paper from
third grade to ninth grade and then I had
to sign a form or something
because I was too young to work
on. No. Then I started caddying.
I was a caddy for awhile. Did that
feel like a fucking year or something?
Then I just started. I always had a
job. It was great. I always had money.
The worst fucking thing
in the world now is that
little boys and girls,
they can't be taking,
they can't be paper boys and girls
anymore. It was the fucking best.
He didn't have to hit your parents
up from, I just, I had fucking money.
Do you understand that?
Okay.
I was making like eight, nine, 10
bucks a week when I was in third grade.
Okay.
I mean I was stuffing it in the walls.
I had like no overhead.
I mean I went the fuck was I going
to spend it on football cards.
That's what I spent it on.
And I had a little bank and I
just stuffed it in there and uh,
anytime I wanted something, if I,
if I wanted to, uh, I used to like,
I had a job and I was so young. Then when
I had a job I would buy toys with it.
I Buy Football Cards and candy,
soda and all that Shit.
I just was fucking great.
Or one time I rode my bike all the way
to fucking Mcdonald's with a buddy of
mine. We both lied to our parents. We were
riding down a fucking two lane highway.
Nobody reported us cause
there was no phones, you know,
we drove all the way down there
and when didn't,
it was the coolest fucking thing I've
been at. Parents had no fucking idea.
I was exhausted because it was one town
over and I just had this little piece of
shit read coaster bike. Um,
and then when I got older I,
I then I, I had, uh, I had
the Raleigh Beach Rambler.
I remember I pointed the bike as I thought
it looked fucking stupid because they
had white wall tires on it. And I pointed
on it and laughed and my dad was like,
oh, I liked that you liked that? And I
was afraid of him, so I just said, yeah,
but this bike I didn't like and that
everybody made fun of me at these giant
peewee Herman fucking tires on it.
But then one day,
you know, we ride down the hill and
everyone was slamming on the brakes.
Like that's what you did for fun
to see it look sort of skid mark,
you could leave.
The tires was so fucking big.
Everybody else's just went like that.
When my skin,
it actually sounded like a car. I went
yep. And everybody thought it was cool,
but it had the big fat ass
fucking seed on it. Um,
but I had a paper route and it's
fucking snowed out and, you know, rain,
sleet or snow, you had to look,
deliver the paper. And Mine, uh,
delivered the Herald and then I
delivered the Boston Globe. And, uh,
I remember the kid down the street,
he had the, he had the coveted route.
There was used to be this paper called
the Patriot ledger and it was an
afternoon paper that makes
any fucking sense. Um,
and it reported on,
I guess I don't know what the stories
that the other papers already reported on.
How am I, how they had advanced over
the last, I don't know how many hours,
whatever. So anyways, uh,
he had it and it was a Monday through
Friday fucking route and it was like,
that thing was with the holy grail
of paper routes in my neighborhood.
And the oldest brother got it and he
passed it onto his next brother. It's,
it's stayed, they had like three boys
and they all had the fucking route.
And the youngest kid was my age,
so there was no way to ever
get the fucking paper route.
So we had the globe, Harold's
first, then the Boston Globe,
and that thing was seven days a week,
three 65.
And I had from third grade to a,
yeah, ninth grade. And I, I don't think,
I haven't missed a day unless
I had a ruptured appendix.
I messed up a couple of weeks that time
and we took a family trip one time when
I was a kid and, uh, and I remember
it's sucked. You'd come back,
these fucking asshole adults would do
your route and he just, you know, I said,
put it in the door.
It was always dry.
They would put a fucking rubber band
around it and elastic, whatever,
fuck you call it. And they
would just drive down the
street and fucking throw it.
You get all these complaints and everyone
would get mad at you and all this shit.
Um, so anyways, I ended, I saved
up my money and I bought that unit.
They get new ovo sport, right.
Really Nice fucking bike. And um,
okay.
I Dunno,
my parents never threw it out.
And I came home one day in my
thirties and I saw it. I was like,
I'm gonna fucking take that thing. All
right. Because, and you just, you know,
represents something to
me. Working hard, you know,
then if you work hard,
you get stuff right.
So I fucking got that thing and it was
all like originals and all that shit and
I just,
it just fucking finally died on me
from years of fucking riding and stuff.
And I decided, um, our guests
sitting in my parents' garage,
I decided that I was going to fix it
up and I finally brought it over to
somebody.
It literally costs me almost the same
amount of money that the bike cost me in
like 1983 when I bought it. And, uh,
I want to get back to riding. I just
have to find where you can ride in La.
That's like safe. I know what the
Santa Monica you can and fucking, uh,
mmm.
I don't know, maybe some of
the parks along the La River,
but I always feel like you're gonna meet
some fucking serial killer down there.
You know, I'll get attacked by a fucking
mountain lion. Ellie is a weird place. Um,
so anyways, let me get back. And I
used to ride that thing when I got,
when I got older,
when I was 21.
Yeah.
I got into the best shape of my
fucking life. Uh, 80 shape, you know,
so no squats.
But what I did for legs was I rode the
bike and I used to ride 11 miles every
day, Monday through Friday, after working
in a warehouse. That's how young I was.
I had the energy to do that.
And on the weekends I would write 18 miles
and I would take one fucking day off.
MMM.
Needless to say,
I won't be doing that again.
I'll fucking take a little
five mile. John's on the
left. One fucking level land.
All right. Sorry. That was in
my entire history with bicycles.
Bikes used to be a big fucking deal,
by the way.
I don't think they're big deals
to kids anymore. Who is freedom?
He just fucking left.
You'd find other kids.
He just fucking wrote around did
shit. You know? I don't know.
I started doing long distance biking.
He said in my twenties,
I was never in bad shape, but I certainly
wasn't in as good as shape as I am now.
Having said all that,
I really hope that once this year you
are able to order yourself a pizza crack
open a highlife and watch nine hours
of football. Yeah, that sounds perfect.
He said none of the hypothetical.
Uh, what would you be,
what would be your combination of
pizza and beer for that occasion? Uh,
I go with a local joint here in
Massachusetts, originally from Cleveland.
Go browns.
Congratulations on your victory.
He said Anna Killian's Irish red
a beer that no one drinks anymore,
but it's delicious.
MMM.
I gotta be honest with
you. I am, I am male.
I am white trash when it comes to beer.
If I could find it,
you know what I would do?
The first beer I ever got drunk
off of was a Michelob light there.
My pizza spot was in Stoughton,
Massachusetts, the town spa.
So I'd have one of their pizzas.
I rarely have a plain one
extra crispy, whatever they do,
you know, well done. And, uh,
I would have a Michelob light and I'd
have it in one of those giant fucking
goblets that they used to have at the
end of the Miller lite commercials. Um,
less fill in? No. Was it less
filling? Tastes great. That's right.
That's what I would do. Um,
New York, my pizza spot,
I haven't lived there a long time. The
pizza place, I used to go to his right,
right next to danger fields cause I would
always ended in that spot and I would
go, it was Sutton pizza,
I think it was called.
And I always thought that they had a
nice sauce and the cheese was on it in a,
complimented the sauce rather than
destroying even being able to taste that
there was any sort of sauce there. Uh,
but I know there's a bunch of, you know,
I haven't lived there in
like fucking 11 years,
so I have no idea what everybody liked
that Joe's pizza down the village was a
big one. Um, but I dunno, I liked
that. That Sutton pizza man.
I fucking like that shit. All
right. Old podcast question. Ah,
dear Billy. Been doing it forever, uh,
was listening to a throwback
on the Thursday podcast.
Great taste in music by
the way. Uh, that's Andrew.
That's his taste in music. If you listen
to mine, it would just be like, yeah,
it'd be bunch of hair metal.
And I was wondering if your feelings
have changed on downloading music and
movies illegally. You are ranting
on and on how terrible it is.
And I'm too young to remember
that controversy. I'm 20,
but you had me convinced it was
certainly illegal and not cool.
Um,
I dunno if it was ever a legal,
what happened was the technology came
about that you could do it. Uh, anyways,
it said something said he had naps.
My friend said he had Napster
in high school and everyone did.
Maybe you said your older brother,
you left out that word.
I guess it's like looking at celebrity
leaks. Celebrity nude photos.
Yeah, it's wrong. But who doesn't
want to get a glimpse of that?
I never look at those fucking things,
but somebody hacks somebodies phone there.
Text messages or emails.
That's none of my fucking businessman.
I see.
I really can't believe like
what fucking voyeurs people are.
I don't give a shit what anybody does.
You know,
and I don't give a fuck what you said
on your phone. And I think if, you know,
like if somebody ever like, oh, can
you believe this person texted this?
This is offensive. It's like,
well they didn't text it to you.
They texted privately to somebody else.
You're not supposed to be reading that.
Don't read other people's text messages.
You won't get fucking offended.
You have no idea what the tone of
that was. This could be a joke.
This could be dead serious,
no fucking idea.
And even still it's like reading stuff,
but I love reading somebody
else's mail is fucking illegal.
But like hacking someone's phone is
fine. I have no idea. Anyways, um,
I guess the only part that I thought you
might have changed your mind on is how
people around the world have heard you,
cause they got it illegally.
Listening to your podcast helps me
sort out my feelings on lots of things,
but also your points make me realize that
the world's has virtually no black or
white issue as well. If you're talking
about my podcast, my podcast is free.
MMM.
But I would say,
um,
okay.
Has it changed? Yeah,
I still pay for music.
MMM.
I go to a iTunes is where I do it.
I don't like those streaming services
because they fuck over the musicians and I
know app I iTunes, they just fuck
him over, man. It's ridiculous.
Itunes does it too. But like
I know, like one of them,
I remember they were talking about me
possibly streaming my, one of my albums,
they're like, yeah, for every
thousand plays we'll give you a,
we'll give you a half a cent.
It's like, go fuck yourself.
They had all his advertising and
shit on the side and everything.
So they getting all this credit and
making all this fucking money and then
you're not even roll in a penny towards
me there that shopping it in half and
then sliding it across the fucking table.
Um,
I will say like, you know, I don't
police a lot of shit too much on youtube.
I should probably do that more.
But um,
okay.
You know, I definitely saw the
advantages. You know, when I went to, uh,
when I went over to Europe,
I gave up my DVDs for free and told
people to upload them onto their youtube
pages because I wanted to get into the,
you know,
different language areas on youtube.
You know,
cause I one time I was trying
to learn to play the rhythm, um,
diverse section of walk this
way on the good on the guitar.
And the only guy did a lesson was a
French guy and I clicked on his fucking
video and then all of a sudden all my
videos to the right word in French and I
was like, wow, what part
of youtube has this?
So when I went to Norway and Sweden
and all those, I was like, you know,
put clips to this up on your page.
I don't give a fuck. You know,
it's on Pirate Bay anyways.
What the fuck do I care?
I might as well get in on this somehow.
So I kind of had to roll with it. But, um,
okay.
No, I, it's, it's still stealing, but
I pay for all my movies. I paid for a,
now that isn't necessarily true
though. There'll be a few, like I try,
I try to pay for movies.
Like if I go on like a Netflix and it
isn't there and I can't find it playing on
cable, you know, and it's something
I really want to fucking see.
I will watch a movie for free.
I'll let, I'll admit that I,
I've definitely done that shit.
Hey,
here's something I want to speak into
that I actually watched a couple of movies
when I was on the plane there.
MMM.
I gotta I gotta show. I
gotta get a shout out to, uh,
you know what sucks is
one of the fucking movies.
I can't even remember the name of the
movie and I really fucking enjoyed it.
Um, fuck. What the hell was I?
I literally watched it's,
Oh, something. Was it Gringo?
Is that the name of the fucking movie?
Charlie's Daren was in it and
she was fucking hilarious.
And her character was, was fucking, I love
the movie. Absolutely loved the movie.
Um, let's see. Gringo,
Charlie's Theron, right? Is
that the name of the movie?
Did I get it right? Yeah.
Gringo. Check that one out.
Love that movie. And then I saw a, Oh
fuck. I gotta answer this. Hang on.
All right, I'm back. Uh, so anyways,
then I watched this other movie called
superfly and was fucking blown away.
Like I couldn't get the fucking,
all the actors names and there was so
many great actors and there was this kid,
I hope it says name it.
It's k a l a n Kr Walker collide.
Kaylon I'll buy say right K or walk to
fucking white to get it right. Walker. He,
his character was so fucking good.
I don't want to ruin the movie.
I just thought the last time you saw him
should have been more of an event with
how good his performance was.
And then the kid who played Superfly's
righthand man was fucking great.
Uh, I, I don't know how to do this without
ruining the fucking move. Sony. Oh,
it's just, it's a really
fun fucking movie. Um,
I've seen some good ones lately, but, uh,
you know, I'm writing this fucking script.
I got into the whole world
are writing scripts now.
So now I'm actually watching movies.
I'm trying to find people,
just remember them.
Oh, were in, in Gringo.
That the fucking dude who played the
guys accountant in the beginning was
fucking great. Uh, everybody
in that movie was great.
So check those out, man. I hope I'm not
doing this shit where I saw it on a plane.
So you're just like, this is fucking
great. It's taken up two and a half hours,
but these were legit could find,
I think. I think they'll hold up.
Even if you just hanging
out at your house, you know,
with your fucking virtual reality glasses
and whatever the fucking internet porn
you're watching, I think you
can get through them. All right.
Those are my recommendations from movies.
Uh,
congratulations to the
fucking lions, man. A huge,
huge fucking victory for
you guys. He turned around.
I'm liking seeing, you know,
the chiefs and all these,
these teams being, I mean,
I obviously don't want the patriots
run to ever fucking end and uh,
I've enjoyed the hell out of it.
And you know, I remember coming up,
it was all about the cowboys and Steelers
and I remember thinking when the fucks
our time and so when we finally had
our time, I enjoyed the whole thing.
I hope it's not over. Um,
but if it is, you know,
it fucking is and I'll be happy for the
rest of my fucking life is what I mean.
What am I going to do?
I'm going to bitch about fucking 10 11
championships straight across the fucking
board in a 15 year period.
It was incredible.
But the red sox is still coming,
you know, who knows. Good
keep could keep going on the
Celtics look fucking good.
I still believe in the Patriots so,
but uh,
it is a lot of fun to see all these
different teams doing well and I'm like
beyond excited to see the next
Brown's game cause I want to see this.
Baker may feel kids.
See if he lights it up again.
That's exciting. All right.
That's it. That's the podcast.
Have a great couple of days. I'll
check on Thursday. Go fuck yourselves.